hello what's your favorite scary movie
who is this what's your favorite scary
movie
oh dr z is this you you really have to
stop at these prank calls but seriously
what's your favorite scary movie
okay we can talk about that later but
i'm filming an episode right now okay
sorry good luck okay bye bye
if you've attended a sleepover party
anytime in the last 50 years chances are
high that you've encountered a prank
call like this maybe you've even made
one yourself but for thousands of years
before the invention of the telephone
pranks fell under the purview of a force
even more powerful than rowdy teens it
was left to the trickster gods
from maui in the southern hemisphere to
amigo in the north trickster gods and
spirits can be found in mythologies
across the globe and their stories are
some of the most fascinating ones like
the chinese tale of sun wukong also
known as the monkey king sun wukong used
his superhuman strength and impressive
shape-shifting abilities to pester the
other gods once he crashed a heavenly
banquet that he was rudely not invited
to drank all the wine and then drunkenly
stole a bunch of immortality pills
for his misbehavior the monkey king was
imprisoned under a mountain for 500
years and his escape provides fodder for
countless modern stories on the other
side of the world the hopi people of the
american southwest told tales of
cocopelli according to one source
cocopelli is described as a lascivious
troublemaker whose obscene behavior
provides an outlet for people's less
socially acceptable desires and reminds
them how they should behave
this flute-playing trickster god is also
a fertility deity who makes his own fun
as he travels the region to spread corn
seed and encourage pregnancy sometimes
through wild parties and erotic dances
this naughty figure is so popular in the
southwest that his image can be found
adorning countless pieces of art and
souvenirs and of course the norse people
gave us what might be the most widely
known trickster of all loki the god of
mischief
much of what marvel reveals about loki
on screen is faithful to the old myths
like his chaotic nature and his
long-held beef with thor even alligator
loki has some foundation in the old
ettas which mention loki's
shape-shifting powers but the mcu's
interpretation of loki is just that
their interpretation in the original
myths thor and loki aren't even brothers
so don't expect to be an expert in norse
mythology after watching tom hiddleston
charm his way to the eventer's bad sides
by the end of this video i'll tell you
about another marvel superhero inspired
by a trickster god but first let's
analyze why the trickster is so common
around the world it has to do with why
myths were told in the first place
before the internet and the scientific
method and even the concept of writing
things down humans told stories for a
few different purposes to explain the
natural world to educate and to
entertain
myths like monsters were created to
explain natural phenomena and reflect
human understanding of the world around
them and throughout time and memorial
one thing that humans have definitely
known about nature is that it's tricky
storms come when you least expect them
animals steal food and other valuable
resources and don't even get me started
on fire a bright light that provides
warmth and prepares your food but can
also burn you and magically turns wood
into ash
sounds like a very elaborate prank to me
a trickster deity is a convenient way to
explain these events indeed in many
mythologies it's a trickster who teaches
humanity how to harness fire myths were
also used to codify social norms for
children and adults alike in mythology
the trickster often faces consequences
for their nefarious hijinks like when
son wukong was imprisoned for eating the
very peaches of immortality that he was
assigned to protect these peaches in
addition to the pills he stole before
made sun wukong extra invincible
this lets everyone who hears the story
know that an immortal god could not run
their punishment and neither can you and
finally trickster stories are fun and
funny just like an entertaining myth is
supposed to be the chaos and randomness
inherent to a trickster persona often
make us laugh
psychologists who study humor have found
a few theories about what makes
something funny and incongruity is one
such theory we find something funny when
there's a mismatch between our
expectations and reality and randomness
creates the opportunity for that
hilarious juxtaposition
in one norse myth the giant escadi
demands to be compensated for her
father's murder and insists that one of
the gods needs to make her laugh
loki is apparently the only norse god
with a sense of humor so he tied one end
of a rope to a goat and the other to a
very
sensitive part of his body and then
squealed with pain as the goat ran away
it must have been a you had to be there
kind of joke because scotty was
appropriately amused and agreed not to
kill the gods so tricksters can be found
in so many different mythologies because
nature is violent everywhere and the
crafty qualities of the trickster make
this particular archetype the perfect
vehicle for delivering moral or
practical lessons in a fun memorable
package across cultures tricksters share
many characteristics they're
unpredictable are often able to
shapeshift and they rely on their quick
wit and penchant for mischief to get
them out of hairy situations
one trickster that embodies all of these
qualities is anansi the trickster god of
knowledge and stories who originated
with the akkan people of ghana in west
africa christianity has been the
dominant religion in ghana for nearly a
century but traditional akan religion is
polytheistic their pantheon is ruled by
a supreme creator god who goes by many
names sometimes nyame
second to nayame is assassina a goddess
of the earth and together they have many
children and messengers of lesser power
known as a bosom
among some anansi is the most important
of these children
often depicted as a spider with a man's
head or a man with eight legs anansi
plays a key role in some fundamental
akan stories according to one the human
world was originally bereft of stories
until anansi got bored one day and
decided to buy them from his dad nyame
the sky god said that anansi could have
his stories for a steep price anansi had
to bring him four of the hardest
creatures to catch onini the python the
hive of maboro hornets osebo the leopard
and a fairy but anansi uses his cunning
and his target's weaknesses to capture
each one
impressed nyame granted anansi ownership
of his stories and anansi shared them
with humanity
but lest you think that makes him a good
guy there's another story where anansi
tries to hoard all the wisdom in the
world by trapping it in a pot and
sticking it at the top of a tree except
the pot was much bigger than a nanzy and
he had trouble carrying it to the top
until his son untakuma suggested he
place it on his back anansi was so
shocked that he hadn't thought of the
answer himself that the pot slipped from
his grip the pot shattered on the ground
and a storm carried away the wisdom
inside to the rest of the world
in yet another story anansi brings
disease to the world in an angry act of
revenge after his father took all of his
wives from him in niame's defense anansi
did promise to bring him a beautiful
wife in exchange for one of his
delicious sheep and then used that sheep
to woo several new wives who he kept for
himself when the atlantic slave trade
forced west africans from their home and
enslaved them across an ocean they took
stories of anansi with them they held
onto him as a symbol of resistance as a
reminder that with a little bit of
cunning and resilience even something as
small as a spider can escape most tough
situations
now stories of anansi have spread and
morphed across the caribbean and the
americas making their way into plenty of
popular media like neil gaiman's mr
nancy from american gods or spider-man
that's right it's marvel canon that in
an alternate universe earth 7082 to be
precise the very first spider-man was
kwaku anansi whether it's displayed on
the silver screen told around a campfire
or painted on the wall of a cave
trickster stories remind us to roll with
the punches that life throws at us and
to face obstacles with cunning instead
of force
the trickster's most important
characteristic is their unpredictability
you never know if a trickster in a story
will be the hero or the villain or
merely the fool providing comic relief
their flexibility is what makes them so
effective and appealing
and if you start looking for them you'll
see tricksters everywhere from
prometheus tricking the gods into giving
us fire to the roadrunner beeping his
way through a world where the laws of
physics don't mean a thing
comment below with your favorite
trickster figure and remember prank
responsibly
you